-President Trump and one of
his closest allies in Congress
have spent the week
whining about people
who are mean to them.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
One of the core themes
of Trump's campaign
was that he'd be tough.
He promised to return
to an era where people
weren't so sensitive
and politically correct,
and he called
his opponents weak.
In fact, there was one insult he
kept returning to over and over.
-We have a bunch of babies
running our country, folks.
We have a bunch of losers.
They're losers. They're babies.
Oh, please. Please.
Don't be a baby, okay?
I know all these things.
I mean, I'm not a baby.
I'm not saying I trust everybody
in the White House.
I'm not a baby.
Our companies
have been just taken
like we're a bunch of babies.
We're losing our jobs
like a bunch of babies.
[ Laughter ]
Babies don't have jobs.
Which means he has fired a baby.
"Take your crib and go."
And, of course,
it's not just Trump.
Right-wing pundits
on Fox News and elsewhere
have been lecturing progressives
for years
not to be so sensitive
about stuff like, say, racism,
and they love
to use schoolyard disses
they think are really cool.
-America's left-wing
college professors
and other snowflakes on campus.
-Tonight, a quiz.
Are you a snowflake?
-Actually, most of the
snowflakes work at CNN and NBC.
-I don't give a damn
what the little snowflakes
think about anything.
-We have a very special guest.
A therapy llama.
All these snowflakes in college,
they get so stressed out,
you know,
they like to pet the llama,
and we're going to
show you guys that.
-Oh! Oh, a therapy llama.
Maybe you can bring it
to the White House.
It'll blend into
the President's hair.
[ Laughter ]
And yet -- And yet...
the guy who called
his opponents babies
has spent his entire term
as president
whining about people
being mean to him,
from "Saturday Night Live"
to John McCain to Google.
In fact, this morning,
he once again lashed out
at George Conway, the husband
of one of his advisers,
Kellyanne Conway.
George Conway is a longtime
Republican lawyer in D.C.
who has called Trump
mentally unfit for office.
And as always, Trump
could not help but fire back.
-He says this --
"George Conway,
often referred to
as Mr. Kellyanne Conway
by those who know him, is very
jealous of his wife's success
and angry that I, with her help,
didn't give him the job
he so desperately wanted.
I barely know him,
but just take a look.
A stone-cold loser
and husband from hell."
-I'm sorry, but you are
the last person
who should call anyone else
the husband from hell.
You've been divorced twice, you
paid hush money to a porn star,
your affairs
were all over the tabloids,
and you misspelled
your wife's name.
If anything...
[ Cheers and applause ]
If anything, "Husband From Hell"
sounds like the name
of a Lifetime movie about you.
And I hate to tell you,
but just like "SNL" did,
they're gonna get Alec Baldwin.
Trump can't let -- He can't let
go of even the pettiest feuds.
For example, this week,
he repeatedly slammed
the late senator and war hero
John McCain.
Trump is still mad
that McCain voted against
his healthcare bill
with that infamous thumbs-down,
which I have to say
is an effective way to say no
to a pushy [bleep]
like Donald Trump.
Based on every picture of Trump,
he probably didn't even know
thumbs could even go that way.
[ Laughter ]
"Where do I --
So I stand on my head?"
[ Laughter ]
Trump...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump has been attacking McCain
in tweets and comments
to reporters all week,
and then today he complained
that McCain didn't thank him
for letting him have a funeral.
-I endorsed him at his request.
And I gave him the kind
of funeral that he wanted,
which as president,
I had to approve.
I don't care about this.
I didn't get "thank you."
That's okay.
-Because he was dead.
Man, you know...
I don't know
if McCain's a ghost,
but he's clearly haunting you.
Trump's always been obsessed
with even the smallest
perceived slights,
but lately
he and his fellow conservatives
have turned their attention
to a new target -- the Internet.
They think the Internet
is biased against them.
In fact, Trump has become
obsessed with the idea
that Google in particular
is rigged to make him look bad.
-"Facebook, Google, and Twitter,
not to mention
the corrupt media," he says,
"are so on the side of
the radical-left Democrats."
-"Google is helping China
and their military,
but not the U.S.
Terrible.
The good news is
they helped crooked
Hillary Clinton and not Trump.
How did that turn out?"
-"Google search results
for 'Trump news'
shows only the viewing reporting
of fake-news media.
In other words,
they have it rigged."
-In fairness to Trump,
he probably thinks Google
is biased against him
because if you search his name,
all the results are bad.
In fact, if you type
"Donald Trump" into Google,
you just get an error message
that says,
"Why are you doing this
to yourself?"
And it isn't just
the news articles that are bad.
Even the "people also
search for" tab is damning.
Three of the top results are
Michael Cohen, Robert Mueller,
and Barack Obama.
Pretty easy to see
the thought process there.
He committed crimes
with Michael Cohen
and is being investigated
by Robert Mueller,
and can we go back
to Barack Obama?
Conservatives...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Conservatives have been whining
about media bias for decades.
It is not sincere.
They're just working the refs
because they don't want
fair treatment --
they want special treatment.
And now they're doing the same
thing to social-media companies.
And the dumbest example of that
came this week
from California Republican
Congressman Devin Nunes.
He's the guy who was in charge
of the Russia investigation
in the House
until he had to step down
because he was bad at his job.
Remember him?
The guy who looks like
when you open your phone and
the front-facing camera is on?
You know, Michael Scott,
but somehow dumber-looking?
Like Trump,
Nunes has been whining
about social-media bias
against conservatives,
but now he's going
one step further.
He's suing Twitter
for supposedly censoring him
and for allowing fake Twitter
accounts to be mean to him.
And he's suing
those fake accounts, too.
Nunes, who is also
a dairy farmer,
is suing two parody accounts
called -- and this is real --
Devin Nunes' Mom
and Devin Nunes' Cow.
[ Laughter ]
That is right.
Devin Nunes is suing a fake
account called Devin Nunes' Cow,
and he's mad because
it got too many re-teats.
[ Cow moos ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
The next card says,
"Audience carries me out
on their shoulders,"
but I don't think...
We'll skip it.
[ Laughter ]
But that wasn't the dumbest part
of the lawsuit.
The dumbest part was the fact
that in order to make his case,
Nunes provided example tweets
from the fake accounts,
tweets that until now
most people
had never even seen before.
For example, the account
Devin Nunes' Mom
posted a graphic claiming
that Trump, Putin, and Nunes
were attached to each other
like a human centipede.
Nunes put that graphic
in his lawsuit.
[ Laughter ]
Dude! What is wrong with you?!
Before you filed this lawsuit,
no one had ever seen that.
It's like you passed out
at a party,
and someone drew a dick
on your forehead,
so you got mad and took a selfie
and put it on Instagram.
And to be clear -- to be clear,
we here at "Late Night"
would never have made
a graphic like this,
and we certainly would
never have been allowed
to show it on TV,
but now it's part
of an official lawsuit
by a member of Congress,
and we have to show it.
In fact, and again --
Again, I hate --
I hate that I had to do this.
But legally, I had to have it
printed on a T-shirt.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There we go.
We might even sell it
in the NBC Store
in that secret room behind the
door that says "Weird [Bleep]."
You know, where they keep the
anatomically correct Alf dolls.
Just to give you an idea
of how badly
this lawsuit has backfired,
in the lawsuit,
Nunes' lawyers write
that the account
Devin Nunes' Cow
had 1,204 followers.
Obviously,
that's a very small number.
But as of this taping,
because of the publicity
from the lawsuit,
Devin Nunes' Cow had --
and, again, this is real --
471,000 followers.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, by the way, we've had to
change that number all day.
When this airs
six hours from now,
I'm sure it'll be like
a 1.5 million.
In fact, the fake cow account
now has more followers
than Devin Nunes' real account.
Even Devin Nunes' actual cows
are following it now.
So a Republican congressman
is suing people for being mean
to him on Twitter,
and the President is
feuding with a senator
who is no longer alive.
There's nothing I can say to
make you guys feel better but...
can I get you a free T-shirt?
This has been "A Closer Look."